[Music]
I came on at a period of time when foot
patrol was a big part of what we did as
cops I'm going back over 45 years now
well we got highly motorized and we were
reactive and moving from 911 call to 911
call foot patrol became something was
pretty much limited to commercial
corridors in many cities if they had
foot patrol at all I think if you talk
to some of my colleagues at this level I
was the one who introduced the
idea and one of whom Deputy bethl who
will tell you he was very reluctant I
didn't think it was going to work you
know uh you know I knew commissioner
Ramy was making that part of a strategy
uh had no experience other than putting
my foot beads in my business Carters uh
actually immersing them in the
neighborhood I just didn't think it was
the best strategy at the
time
now the first time we did it uh we
didn't have Temple involved in it we
just kind of put it out there and we did
it my sense was that foot patrol was an
effective strategy not just the
feel-good strategy but how do you really
know so the next year when we decided to
do it that's when we got Temple involved
to actually take a look at areas of the
city
small areas of the city where crime was
occurring in open space with a large
class graduating from the police academy
we had the opportunity to conduct a
city-wide evaluation for the police
department we designed the Philadelphia
foot patrol experiment as a randomized
controlled field experiment we used
crime mapping techniques to identify the
top 1% of violent crime intersections in
the city this map was provided to the
police department who drew small concise
foot beats around the main areas where
they wanted to
Target
from these 120 areas we randomly
selected 60 to be the places where we
would place the foot beats for the
summer and these aren't commercial
corridors I mean these are little
neighborhoods these are places where
we've got you drug trafficking other
types of disorder just crime that occurs
in public space could be theft forato
what have you the other
60 we didn't take away resources we just
didn't add any resources so we responded
to the crime like we always responded to
the crime
[Music]
it yielded results that I never expected
even in my wild the streams after 3
months violent crime was 23% lower in
the foot patrol sites compared to the
equivalent control locations there was
also a reduction in vehicle crime the
commanders who initially were naysayers
some of whom wanted know parts of it you
started to see that change where
subsequent to that first year and they
saw the results they they started to see
them on their own districtwide level and
the impact that the footbeats had
particularly when we reduced them to
manageable
sizes man I got to tell you it was a
good feeling to see them clamoring for
future foot beats and not wanting to
give them
[Music]
up but when you're out there on foot and
you're walking and you're interacting
and you see two people sitting on the
porch and you're able to stop and
actually have a conversation when you
see kids that uh live in that
neighborhood and you know the good kids
from the ones that tend to get in
trouble you know who they
are these are relationships and
connections that you just simply don't
get when you're driving 40 m an hour
down the street what I will find that
many of my commanders will say when they
get those foot beats they really really
are prepared um though they have some
issues to catch up with because they
have not been in the car those easy
getting them in the car running from job
to job man that that that part is the
easier part but they've walked those
blocks in some of the toughest
neighborhoods and they've got to know
residents in those tough neighborhoods
and they start to realize whoa these are
they're good people on these
[Music]
blocks
once you partner with a university it's
one thing like the commissioner always
says to to believe that you're doing
something effective it's another thing
when you research proves it and it makes
you really feel good about not only your
tactics but the fact that you're on the
right track and that you're you're
developing something meaningful well I
think evidence-based policing is really
the future I think it's it makes sense
and I think that now having Partnerships
with researchers and academics is really
adding an entirely new dimension to
policing it was a collaboration from the
very beginning you know it was everybody
checked their Eagles at the door and we
all wanted the same things um and so I
think it was probably one of the one of
the most uh one of the best projects
I've been involved with in my
[Music]
career
oh